hugo pratt imaginer qu'au lieu d'être un
jour la vie je sois une jolie fille que
vous rencontrez comme s'asseoir sur un
sur un bateau sur la seine
est-ce que vous aussi vous êtes l'auteur
de corto maltese jamais jamais autant
c'est connu dans le monde entier ce qui
évidemment se fait partout l' affaire
c'est que plusieurs fois je me suis
trouvé avec des gens même des caisses
qui si il me demandait c'est moi je
connais automatique alors des primes est
forcément jeudi normalité c'est une
affaire peu par fallu pour que quand on
était seulement une fête commerciale à
lorient mais regarde
j'ai commencé il y avait d'amendé
boutiques dont 1 mais commençait à
parler
oui mais c'est mon malin consommateurs
je crois qu'il est un prétendu où il est
à kaboul où il a dit savait pas où se
trouve à buenos aires et si mike ridell
mirlesse je crois que c'est à bâle la
semaine
la semaine dernière je suis obligé de
vous avez l'impression d'avoir inventé
un personnage aussi important sur la fin
pourquoi non parce que la différence est
quelqu'un avec du simple 120 millions dé
livres et moi je ne crois pas d arriver
à ses possibilités c'est tout à fait une
autre chose
ces quelques en plus de gens qui sont le
loup corto maltese avec les cheveux la
boucle d'oreille lait les pâtes un peu
gros comme ça et qui à paris on
rencontre de plus en plus de gens qui se
font le loup corto maltese vous savez ça
mais je trouvais quelques fois
c'est à venise exemple avec les frères
noël il a toujours chaque année va il a
un thème des décors thomas tgb se
promène comme un peu la place normale
elle puis c'est légal dans ces zones
mais chemin bloc ou le croyons dur
[Musique]
olivier backes beaucoup barbu la barre
d'écouté
je vois il tâte et chose mais je ne
crois pas de cette façon non c'est pas
dur de vivre sans toi rendu à toquer
manger je m'arrangeais
[Musique]
ça vous embête pas de faire corto
maltese jusqu'à la fin de vos jours vous
ai pas le sentiment ex prisonnier qui
est prisonnier les qui vous prenez quoi
vous travaillez ou du vin verts vont
fumer un joint ou es ce que vous avez
des trucs comme ça vous fait quoi pour
aider votre imagination
[Musique]
me bringer manger mali mentalement aussi
l objet d'aider des choses dynamique et
c'est pas des choses interdites si tu
portais déjà zidani vous voulez trouver
les choses politiques quelquefois sur le
meilleur si vous me demandez c'est moi
j'aime la belle cure chimiques
alors je dis que là c'est plus dangereux
non c'est un bon whisky de vin à
l'orangé monsieur tous les parents j'ai
vu comment les espaces 18d voir si
simone j'en arrive même à messieurs les
uns parce que moi j'ai voir ce monsieur
papa et les pointures de ne rien rater
de 1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais 1
pouces bleus